there's a video just went around
of a a guy at a New York City all ages
drag show not wearing any pants wearing
a thong wearing stiletto heels jiggling
around teaching a little girl and then
even a little girl who I don't know I'd
Place her age let's say around seven or
eight I can't really tell from the
picture and and in front of kids who are
much younger even than that
I have mercifully
blurred out this man's nauseating
derriere
but he's Dan it's not even as though the
guy jiggling around half naked on stage
doesn't know that the little kids are
watching he's doing it for the kids
they're in the front row and he's
looking at the girl who's dancing around
with him and teaching her how to twerk
and so now we're all going to be
outraged we're gonna be outraged
and we need to yell about this and we're
can you imagine this is weird this is
bizarre
conservatives look I'm guilty of it too
we all do it we look at this bizarre
behavior we say that's bizarre that's
weird
sort of is it really bizarre in today's
day and age no it happens all the time
we cover it on the show three times a
week
it happens all the time
we can be repulsed by this we can be
nauseated by this we should not be
shocked by this we should not be
surprised this is what has been
happening for years
and this has been a phenomenon
accelerating the culture for decades
and it is not going to stop
until we make it stop
this is not going to stop
until we
enforce laws that are already on the
books against this kind of stuff public
indecency laws obscenity laws and it's
not going to stop until we throw these
people in prison
yeah we can publicize it we can talk all
I've got right here is a microphone and
a camera so we can talk about it we can
expose it a lot of people aren't totally
aware that this is happening and they
don't even but when they hear about it
they don't even believe wait this guy's
doing what in front of kids what no
there's no way I can't believe it and
then you see it so it helps you realize
the problem is real
but it's not going to stop just because
we shine a light on it it will only stop
when we throw these people in prison
okay and a lot of conservatives say well
we don't I don't want to do that that's
the big government
that's the naughty evil big government
I've been told that we can never use the
government to do anything because that
would that would make us no different
from the Liberals you see if I arrest
child Predators who prepares around half
naked in front of five-year-olds that
well really that'd be no different than
if I were a liberal and I arrested a
preacher wouldn't it so let's not do
that let's just complain about it now if
we complain enough then then they'll
they'll
voluntarily stop doing all the Terrible
Things no they won't
they obviously won't
so what are we gonna we're doing what we
can do
okay we are exposing this stuff showing
you what a problem it is
and then the people listening to this
show
the great Grassroots activists around
the country
you are all doing what you can do you
were showing up to school boards you're
showing up to your local government
you're writing your Congressman you're
yelling at them you're sometimes
throwing the bums out
the Republicans have to do their job
enforce the law in the cases where laws
have been repealed put new laws on the
books
throw these people in prison wield your
power pull an Elon pull an Elon sell all
the Liberals toys okay get rid of all
the Liberals toys the drag queens and
the stilettos and the and the weird
luggage and the Sam Brinton accessories
and get rid of it make an example assert
some freaking strength and fortitude and
political dominance on the occasions you
get it or when this continues to happen
you'll have no one to blame but yourself
politicians
what are we getting I have the proof of
this Joe Biden just signed this bill
into law to abolish marriage and
uh the the the law it's called the what
what are they calling it the respect for
Marriage Act but all it really does is
define marriage out of existence and Joe
Biden to celebrate this wonderful event
has invited a drag queen to the White
House
drag queen Marty G Cummings uh is is
attending the respect for marriage act
at the White House and he says to be a
non-binary drag artist invited to the
White House is something I never
imagined would happen yeah you and me
both brother grateful doesn't begin to
express the emotions that I feel
so the political order encourages this
stuff that's why it happens
and the only way that you're going to
get rid of it
is to create political conditions in
which this sort of thing is unpleasant
there have always been transvestites
there have always been Unix there have
always been people who are sexually
depraved and Confused their behavior for
most of our history has been relegated
to back alleys
to the Shadows to the fringes which is
where this sort of thing belongs if
because it is a Fallen World We are
never going to get rid of perverts uh
desire to take off half their clothing
and jiggle their derriere in front of
five-year-olds you're actually not going
to just get rid of that so what can you
do about it the only thing you can do is
relegate that to the Shadows create the
political Commissions in which that sort
of thing is considered very very
shameful and not elevated to the status
of a White House presidential signing
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]